we had one instance in a hotel room
where he tried to where he made a pass
at me
and then I really kind of stood up to
him I told my boyfriend at the time Brad
Pitt Brad Pitt who by the way I love him
for this I love him for this too you
told him
hey Harvey just did something really
weird and Harvey's moves are weird
it was weird yeah it was weird here's a
guy who's your he's like a dad to you
yeah I was shocked when you tell Brad
Brad says [ __ ] this guy I'm gonna go
over and confront him so what happened
was I told him right away and I was very
shaken by the whole thing and I had two
movies I'd signed up to do two movies
with him are you afraid that the movies
would be canceled it would be free yeah
sure cuz this was a good thing and Brad
Pitt's we were at a the opening of
Hamlet on Broadway that ray Fiennes was
in Hamlet and ha and Harvey was there
and Brad Pitt it was like the equivalent
of throwing him against the wall you
know energetically it was like were you
afraid though did you
was it really and this I mean great guy
Brad Pitt for doing that but at the same
point to it's your story it's your
relationship with Harvey as most guys do
they take action right when when you
come home and say Harvey just did a
weird thing to me I'm gonna do something
rare yeah maybe you weren't even looking
for that like he took it upon himself to
confront Harvey I it was so fantastic
because what he did was he leveraged his
fame and power to protect me at a time
when I didn't have fame or power yet
right Wow it moves you yeah it was it
was fantastic
good for him yeah he's a good person oh
you must have just you know I guess part
of me was like who's Brad Pitt to take
up your cause you didn't tell him to do
that but at the same point oh my gosh
he's very heroic and and Harvey was
never inappropriate with me again Wow
I just like Brad Pitt sticking up for
you he's the best wonder what he said
did he ever tell you what he said to
Harvey yeah because he came back and
told me exactly what he said anyways he
like
[ __ ] you you ever lay a hand on my
girlfriend I'm gonna kill you he said if
you ever make her feel uncomfortable
again I'll kill you or something like
that that's awesome
yeah